there will be human beings in the
factory of the future but much more in a
creative job in a surveillance job
rather than in simple consecutive steps
of working hi I'm seguros firm CEO of
the industry sector of Simmons and here
we show how the car manufacturing of the
future will look like what we see here
is a much closer merge of the digital
and the real world in manufacturing so
we get much more efficiency we get much
more flexibility and we can provide
shorter time to market as engineering is
much easier than it was in the past and
in currently scale is different variants
of cars can be built on one line while
in the past and still in many car
manufacturing sites you have a specific
line pro model this is a very versatile
one so depending on what customer car is
next it can be very different models
that can be handled here on that line we
have all the car manufacturers around
the world in our customer lists we do
specific products with each of them this
is just one example but they are all our
esteemed customers